وهنتابع معكم الجوانب الاخرى من المونديال
حيث اكتمل المربع الذهبي من كاس العالم
المثير كرواتيا والارجنتين المغرب وفرنسا
صعد ليونيل ميسي وحده دون غريمه التقليدي
تاريخي كريستيانو رونالدو ميسي تاهل مع
الارجنتين الى نصف نهائي المونديال بعد
مشاركته في مباراه قد تكون الامتعه في
البطوله امام منتخب الطواحين الهولنديه
تعادلت هولندا في الثانيه الاخيره من
الوقت بدل الضائع شيطان اضافيه ثم ركلات
ترجيحيه افتتح ليه والتسجيل فيها لراقصه
تانجو لكن رونالدو لن يرافق ميسي ولم
يلتقي في النهائي كما اراد الحالمون ان
تنتهي القصه بدا رونالدو اخر مشاركه له في
كاس العالم على مقاعد البدلاء قبل ان يدخل
في الشوط الثاني لم يسجل لم يصنع غادر
رونالدو بالدموع متحسرا على فرصه ضائعه
ورقصه اخيره ولقب لم يحصل عليه ابدا ولن
يضمه لكثيرا جدا من انجازاته الفرديه
والجماعيه الى لبس
اكتمل المربع الذهبي لكاس العالم بعد
دراما كرويه هائله في الدور ربع النهائي
من البطوله ومفاجاه الاطاحه بالبرازيل
وانجاز مغربي الى قبل النهائي اليكم بعض
الاحصائيات والارقام
ميسي يعادل موطنه باتيستوتا اكثر لاعب سجل
الارجنتين بتاريخ المونديال برصيد 10
اهداف البرازيل تخرج من الدور ربع النهائي
للمره الرابعه خلال اخر خمس مشاركات
بتاريخ كاس العالم كرواتيا اول منتخب
بتاريخ كاس العالم يصل المربع الذهبي وهو
يملك فوز واحده فقط كرواتيا تتاهل بركلات
الترجيح في دوري 16 والربع النهائي
للمونديال الثاني على التوالي فرنسا تفوز
على انجاز لاول مره في كاس العالم بعد
الخساره في نسختي 1982 و 1966
اول ركله جزاء لانجلترا بتاريخ كاس العالم
شباك فرنسا تتلقى اهدافا في جميع
مبارياتها بهذا المونديال خمسه لقاءات
تحديدا لاول مره منذ عام 1950
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وربما يضاف اليهم دموع ميسي لا نعرف حتى
الان
ان شاء الله
هيك تعليق سريع عليه
خلفك فيها من المغرب بيكون بطل كاس العالم
لكن انا
شخصيا واعتقد ما بتكلمش بالنيابه عن حد
لكن بشكل عام العالم كله يا اهل يقهل نفسه
ان يكون ميسي هو بطل كاس العالم
بيكون في المباراه النهائيه ولكن على
الارجح هي فرنسا والارجنتين طيب خليني انا
استوقف ان انت بتقول فرنسا والارجنتين بس
فرنسا والارجنتين خسروا امام منتخبات
عربيه
منتخب المغرب على اقصاء فرنسا ولا تقصدي
شيء اخر اذا اذا اذا اذا ده اللي بنتمناه
اكيد لكن فنيا المساله صعبه جدا في فرق
بيننا نتكلم بعضفه ونتكلم بشيء من
الواقعيه بالتاكيد للمره المليون اكيد ما
في ما في ابدا شك ان احنا نتمنى منتخب
المغرب وبالمناسبه هو لديه فرصه امام
فرنسا ولكن فرصه ليست قويه كثيره ليه
يسمحي لي اقول لك سريعه منتخب المغرب خلاص
افتقد بعنصر المفاجاه اللي فجاه بين
المنتخبات في المراحل الماضيه ومنتخب
فرنسا هيستعد لك ومنتخب فرنسا هو اقوى
منتخب في البطوله بشكل مطلق ولكن في بصيص
من الامل في بعض الجوانب سريعالج منتخب
فرنسا لديه بعد العناصر المنير يشاركني في
الراي تميل الى الاداء الفرج لما يكون
عندك منتخب متماسك زي منتخب المغرب عنده
فرصه انه يعبر من منتخب يغلب عليه احيانا
طبعا الاداء الفريق
واكيد كل المشاهدين وكل الناس اليوم عم
تتسائلي قبل ان انتقل اليك منير عم بتقول
كيف ستبدو الشوارع فرنسا في مباراه المغرب
وفرنسا لانه يعني الجاليه المغربيه اكبر
جاليه عربيه افريقيه موجوده في فرنسا
الشوارع حتكون مليئه السكان ومقتظه ونتمنى
الا تحصل اعمال شغب طيب منير اليوم ما هي
نقاط الضعف لدى منتخب البرتغال عندما
نتحدث عن امور تقنيه التي استفادت ربما
منها المغرب
شفت نادين انا بالنسبه لي يعني مباراه
اسبانيا كانت اصعب على المغرب من مباراه
البرتغال يعني امكانيات
اسلوب لعب المنتخب الاسباني اقوى ويعني
واسرع حتى في في رتم المباراه لكن انت لك
المنتخب المغربي لاقوى خط وسط الى اليوم
في المونديال يعني احبطت كل المحاولات
الهجوميه المنتخب الاسباني غير ثلاث مرات
طريقه اللعب امام المغرب ولم ينجح في
اختراق خط الوسط بالامس ايضا المنتخب
البرتغالي حاول يعني همم المنتخب
البرتغالي معروف يملك يعني اجنحه سريعه
جدا همم بدخول كريستيانو رونالدو اصبحت
الكرات العرضيه هي السلاح لكن لم ينجح
المنتخب البرتغالي لماذا لانه خط الدفاع
كان في افضل الحالات كانتي جيد لم يسمح
لاي لاعب برفع الكوره وهذا امر يعني همم
كان ايجابي جدا خط الوسط لم تكون هناك
مساحه للاختراق او التوغل او التسديد من
خارج منطقه 18 متر فهذه عوامل مهمه جدا
ترجح كفه المغرب في مواجهه اي منتخب قوي
بس محمد يعني كان يرجح فوز فرنسا على
المغرب في المباراه المقبله يوم الثلاثاء
بناءا على هذا شو الاستراتيجيه التي يجب
ان يتخذها المنتخب المغربي ربما لمواجهه
المنتخب الفرنسي يوم الثلاثاء ربما كان في
استراتيجيات مختلفه حسب كل البلد وحسب كل
مهاجم معروف يعني كلام محمد يعني منطقي
وسليم يعني وعقلانه طبعا جدا المنتخب
الفرنسي اقوى منتخب اليوم في كاس العالم
وهو المرشح للفوز باللقب والاحتفاظ يعني
لكن همم لن ننسى انه المنتخب المغربي يعني
امام البرتغال وامام اسبانيا غير التكتيك
ولحمه بطريقه مختلفه يعني شاهدنا امام
البرتغال اكثر يعني سعودي الى الامام اكثر
محاولات على الاطراف يعني هناك
اسلوب لعب مختلف عن الاسلوب الذي لعب به
امام اسبانيا بالتاكيد امام فرنسا لن يلعب
بالتاكيد مثلما من اللاعب امام البرتغال
وامام اسباني هناك يعني عوامل همم قوه
اكثر ومتنوعه اكثر بالنسبه للمنتخب
الفرنسي يعني ممكن ان يستعين بالمدرب
منتخب تونس لفك شفره المنتخب الفرنسي في
هذه المباراه لكن طبعا همم امزح فقط
اثبت انه مدرب يعني قادر على قراءه
المباريات قادر على ايجاد الحلول المناسبه
لايقاف اي منتخب قوي وهذا ما يجعلوني امام
المنتخب فرنسا همم نعم همم يعني نقطه قوه
سريعه وهداف همم يعني هناك اكثر من لاعب
مميز في المنتخب الفرنسي القوه المنتخب
في مسحه تم تداولها يوم امس لانه جورجينا
صديقه كريستيانو رونالدو يعني كانت جدا
غاضبه وقالت له انه خلص يلا نضب الشنط
ونروح قالها بعد المغرب فقط يعني ههه
هذا وطبعا كثير من انه كانت النتيجه من
المزاح كل حال مصطفى اعود اليك لنتحدث
امور تقنيه عندما نتحدث عن مدرب المنتخب
علامات استفهام اليوم كيف تنظرون الى هذا
الدور الذي اوصله لتاهل المغرب الى النصف
النهائي
والله حقيقه
الدور اللي يلعبوه للكابتن وليد الرجراجي
دور كبير يعني ربما نحن تنشاهدوه وتعيشوه
يوميا فبعد ما كان الكل يشكك في قدرات هذا
المدرب الشاب وخاصه انه لاول مره
الفنيه لفريق الوطني
[موسيقى]
يعني همم جميل همم ما تنشوفه في في
السنوات الماضيه لما كانوا يجوا عندنا
مدربين يعني همم نقول احنا عالميين ولكن
هذا مدرب وطني استطع فيه وقت وجيج همم
شهرين او ثلاث شهور انه يجمع الكل هو وراه
خاصه للجمهور المغربي المحبين اللعيبه وصل
للعيبه حتى نتكلم عن اللعيبه فتشوفي
الاداء بتاع اللاعيبه كيف يعني اللاعيبه
كلهم بدها تحسسيهم في الملعب يعني كلهم
مركزين هي في 100 او او زياده حتى في
لاعبين يعني ما كنا تن تن اعتقد انهم
يعطوه هذا المستوى همم دفاعي خاصه الدفاع
المدنيش كذلك
لحمه يعني الفريق الواحد اكيد همم الفريق
الوطني همم
اكيد فرنسا هي اللي لازم تخاف من المغرب
لنا احنا تنعاد مباراه فرنسا ولكن فرنسا
لاتعرف المغرب فاكيد هما لازم الفريق
الفرنسي هو اللي لازم يخاف من الفريق
الحكم النتائج اللي حصل
مع مع
اسبانيا مع البرتغال فاكيد احنا لازم نكون
عندنا هذه الحلم صار الحلم الحقيقه اكيد
احنا نفكر الحين
فقره انه في فرنسا
انه لا يفكر في قبل النهائي بل يفكر في
النهايه صح دي اشاره بس دائما
عايز تنجح خذ خطوه بخطوه يجب ان يكون كل
هجسنا الان هو قبل النهائي وفرنسا وليس
النهائي اشكرك
طيب نايف كلمه اخيره لك لنختم معك ماذا
لديك لتضيف
طب علينا
قولي ان شاء الله لا ما نشوف دموع ميسي
انا على الصعيد ههه
[ضحك]
في المباراه الاخيره همم
الارجنتين ما تحملت اني اشوفها لكن انا في
حاله واحده بتقبل دموع ميسي اذا كانت
المغرب في بطل كاس العالم
بكاس العالم
ههه
لا انا بتحمل بتحمل وانا كذلك
في ايام مقبله نحو نصف النهائي ونحو ايضا
الختام ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من الامارات مدرب
رياضي مصطفى بركه وفي الاستديو والصحه في
الرياضي محمد حامد وايضا الاعلام الرياضي
مني راح وشكرا شكرا شكرا